this tournament is very long and very
taxing physically how important is it
for you to relax and re-energize after
each and every game the games are
extremely tiring of course as we as we
go with the tournament it gets more and
more tiring and also there's lots of
emotions and lots of physical exhaustion
basically So eventually you're going to
run out of energy from from every
possible aspects and then you are just
going to be looking that I think the
best players are the ones who you can
cope with this situation or basically
the Regis situation as late as possible
in the tournament or who can complete
the best and to come on over their way
through the fatigue and the bunch of
errors that will eventually creep in and
um and they can bounce back quickly it's
important uh if you think differently
see my games from the match
yeah of course learn to rest after long
and top championship match
I didn't expect it's so tough than I
expected but well today after the
opening ceremony I think I was
get into the
appointment I'm ready for tomorrow's
game yeah I think very important say
it's at least half of what the most
important thing you need to do during
retirement you need confidence and a lot
of rest a lot of sleep your brain cannot
function without getting a good night's
rest so you have to balance it with
preparation during interment a lot of
things can happen mistakes happen uh so
you kind of need to be ready those big
moments yeah I think classical chess is
the only format where you have just one
game to prepare for and that really
makes a difference because you can focus
on a particular player or the particular
color and bring your best ideas and have
the time to work them out and get them
into your system so I think that's
that's quite exciting and
You know despite the rapid and place
catching on you still see what class
coaches has to offer and uh kind of
spectacular games we receive yeah for me
sleeping is very important you should
have a sleep at least eight nine hours
because if you will play for six seven
hours so you have to have a lot of rest
if you're tired you cannot mentally be
ready and think
so it's very important physically also
and maintenance
now definitely I
prioritizing after the games you know
getting some rest and getting ready for
the next games and obviously I'm also
doing that on a daily level
with
physical Sports and trying to increase
my my stamina and such to to be ready
for tournaments that are you know tough
and quite exhaustic okay
rest time it's important probably for
every player because they need some rest
and to prepare for the next stop I think
it's almost like the second most
important after just playing good chess
yeah sometimes you you know there are of
course strong emotions involved in the
guns and you have to you have to recover
sometimes you have to you know forget
about the rose game
I think we saw from a match that when
when people get tired they're you know
they're starting to make decisions that
are atypical of them
they they make mistakes that they
normally wouldn't make so stress and
tiredness I can really play a huge role
in terms of lowering your quality or
like at those critical moments you know
and especially when you're low on time
and sometimes you you have to like
switch to Instinct and you just need
like your full capacity so if if you're
a bit tired if you're a bit stressed
these things they you might not even
realize it but they really can play a
huge role
foreign
[Music]